this isn't Peters seminary about an hour
west of Glasgow in Scotland or rather it
was it was built in the 1960s period of
training the school for priests and I
think it's a beautiful ruin of a
building but then I like my best
architecture like this in 1992 this was
put on the list of historic Scottish
buildings in category a which means that
it's of national or international
importance and architectural II it is
one of the most important modern
buildings in Scotland but by the time it
was listed it had already been closed
for years the Catholic Church had
decided that priests should train in
towns and cities not in remote places
like this and besides time for changing
there weren't as many people who wanted
to be priests no one was interested in
buying the place and the church couldn't
afford to keep an empty and extremely
high maintenance building running for no
purpose one of the troubles with a
unique structure like this is that it's
expensive and difficult to keep repaired
so a quarter of a century later what's
left looks the Archdiocese of Glasgow
has been responsible for it since the
moment they opened it was a building
which was very difficult to reuse
because it had been custom-built no
developer wanted a building that had a
huge concrete Chapel in it we have a
responsibility to try and preserve the
ruin as best we can
it is no ruin it's covered in graffiti
it's inaccessible it's dangerous we have
by statute to try and maintain some kind
of security in that area to ensure it
and so on but after 40 years we are at
our wits end in 40 years we have worked
with every imaginable idea developers
have thought of turning into a community
centre or a hotel complex and everything
in between there were inherent
weaknesses in the building those who
lived there have nightmarish stories of
water ingress for example of the fact
that the wind would blow so strongly
through the windows that curtains would
be lifted to be almost horizontal so the
building itself was not an easy building
to live in or work in which made it even
more difficult to find an alternative
use for what an arts organization spent
millions on making it safer removing
Vestas an old fittings using it as a
stage for light shows hoping to turn it
into an arts venue but then they run out
of money and besides by design this
building is in the middle of nowhere
there's a village a mile down the road
but that's it there are better places
for arts venues and there's no way in
law to just abandon a building like this
you can't just decide that it doesn't
spark joy anymore and donate it to a
charity shop and it definitely can't be
knocked down because it's a really
significant listed building so it's not
just a listed building it's a Grade II
listed building it's the highest form of
listing possible we are required to
stick to all sorts of rules a bit not
using it for any alternative purpose not
amending it trying to keep the area
around safe legally we would give that
building away with the estate but
whoever takes it on takes on
responsibility for insurance for
security for upkeep and so on so it's
not so easy
you can't literally can't give it away
that have been expressions of interest
but when it comes down to it it's a
question of money of Finance because the
building itself
swallows vast amounts of money and even
to maintain in its current ruin state
costs the archdiocese something like
60,000 pounds a year people have looked
at the area around because in a
beautiful estate they have looked at
perhaps building houses there and using
the profit from that but that has been
denied because there are green bill
issues which prevent that too and so
there's something tragic about it
there's something haunting about it it's
unrealistic to expect some sort of deus
ex machina we remain open to working
with anyone who wants to come forward
with plans with ideas but at the same
time realistically this is bigger than
us this is something for the state
something for the nation and most people
would probably say what a mess those are
understand buildings and they have an
understanding of brutalist architecture
we'd see it as an extraordinary treasure
that's the reality
it is both if this was centuries-old
rather than decades it'll be a national
treasure the Scottish Government would
probably pay to restore it you could
charge the admission fee parents and
bring the
to picnic in the grounds and the idea of
spraying graffiti on it would be
abhorrent but apparently it isn't
despite the fact that this is a
one-of-a-kind historic religious
building this place has enormous
historical and cultural value but a
negative financial value and that it
turns out is a very difficult place to
be
you